dieser versteinerte dieser fassungslosem
blick und dieses foto das so viel sagt
über das wahre schreckliche ausmaß
dieser flugkatastrophe der blick von
ferdinand wahl bestatter auf die
leichensäcke auf einige der toten dieser
flut meine gedanken sind bei den
angehörigen dieser menschen und gleich
spreche ich mit ihm mit verdienern pfahl
und außerdem habe ich diese wichtigen
fragen an die politik warum so viele
tote bei dieser flugkatastrophe warum
wurden all die warnung vorher so wenig
ernst genommen die richtigen fragen
jetzt live ja warum so viele tote warum
kam diese flut katastrophe für so viele
von uns so überraschend obwohl es doch
so konkrete warnungen vor hergab
diese fragen müssen wir stellen darüber
müssen wir sprechen jetzt mit nordrhein
westfalens innenminister herbert reul
und mit der bürgermeisterin von altenahr
in rheinland pfalz cornelia weigandt
schon guten abend ihnen beiden weigern
zunächst herzliche grüße und unsere
anteilnahme nach rheinland pfalz sind
ihren ort in ihrer gemeinde nach altena
sie sind einer der orte die am
allerschwersten getroffen wurden von
dieser flutkatastrophe bei ihnen auch
heute kein strom wahrscheinlich auf
lange sicht noch kein trinkwasser auch
das wird wahrscheinlich lange noch bei
ihnen so bleiben das handynetz
funktioniert so sporadische moment was
ist das was ihre menschen den alten
namen aller aller dringendsten benötigen
gerade weil das heißt es ist nicht nur
ein ort sondern es sind viele orte an
der arbeit auf nvidia kennt es ist von
ihnen bisher noch das ist das gebiet der
verbandsgemeinde altena und in den
allermeisten dieser orte sieht das
gleich katastrophal aus was wir
dringend benötigen sie haben es gesagt
es sieht so aus als ist die
infrastruktur so stark zerstört dass es
an einigen orten vielleicht über wochen
oder sogar monate kein trinkwasser geben
wird es gibt gerüchte
und die menschen möchten hier
weiterleben und insofern wäre es für uns
sehr wichtig dass es eine möglichkeit
gibt eine notwasserversorgung
gegebenenfalls auch über monate
gewährleisten zu können und es wäre da
wo es auch vielleicht länger langfristig
keinen strom gibt auch eine
notstromversorgung gewährleisten zu
können und dafür mein appell das ist
eine kooperation zwischen den
katastrophenopfern
katastrophenschutzorganisation gibt um
das gewährleisten zu können dass die
menschen eine chance haben diese schwere
zeit ohne
ist hier mit gesendet verweigern ich
möchte dieselbe frage auch nach
nordrhein westfalen geben an den
nordrhein westfälischen innenministerium
reul auch in nordrhein westfalen gibt es
ja diese besonders schwer getroffenen
orte erstattet ist zum beispiel solche
einer was ist jetzt nachdem sie sich im
laden natürlich umgeschaut haben der
ministerpräsident ist getan haben was
ist das was die menschen in genau diesen
ordner aller allernötigsten haben ja die
müssen jetzt erstmal ganz konkrete hilfe
bekommen von den katastrophen
hilfsorganisationen also dafür sorgen
dass keine menschen oder möglichst wenig
menschen zu schaden kommen dass wir die
schäden die passieren in grenzen halten
deswegen ein riesiger aufwand den wir
betreiben
es sind am tag rund 22.000 menschen aus
diesen organisationen unterwegs ich
glaube mittlerweile über 30 tausend
solcher einsätze gefahren große und
kleine und dann beginnt die zweite
etappe wender dass die größte gefahr
beseitigt haben oder in griffen dann
begeht die frage des aufräumens und dann
auch die frage wie kriegen können wir
was können wir tun das politikum
diejenigen die es besonders stark
getroffen hat den zu helfen und das ist
die frage an die politik von
finanzieller unterstützung am ende auch
wissen sie denn herr oil aktuell für
nordrhein westfalen schon haben sie
schon überblick über die todeszahlen
werden die weiter steigen vermuten sie
dass in den nächsten tagen wir haben bis
heute 46 tote davon sind auch vier
feuerwehrleute betroffen die also im
einsatz seien betroffen waren
wir können nicht ausschließen dass es
mehr gibt obwohl die großen
gefahrenherde eigentlich gewarnt sind
aber es gibt halt nur situationen da
sind autos verschüttet die sind zum teil
unter wasser
die müssen jetzt erst mal aufgemacht
werden da weiß man nicht genau ob da
noch was kommt
ich bin allerdings nach guter dinge ist
auch ein falsches wort also ich hoffe
dass wir da die zahlen nicht mehr
wesentlich steigern ganz sicher kann ich
nicht sein weil wir nicht über feinsten
frau weigert wie wird das bei ihnen sein
womit rechnen sie für die gemeinde alten
aa und für weiler
ich weiß es gibt noch riesigen
schuttberge wohnmobile campingwagen
drauf liegen alles da weiß man noch gar
nicht was darunter liegt gehen sie noch
davon aus dass es weitere tote geben
wird zu den ohnehin schon so vielen in
ihrem landkreis
es ist zu befürchten die schuttberge
gerade vor den brücken sind sehr stark
sehr breit
das wird er nichts darin wie in
nordrhein westfalen
wir konnten bis jetzt nur die häuser
sichten in unseren orten und zu unserer
verbandsgemeinde sind hier mehrheitlich
in allen häusern gewesen aber natürlich
auch vorher haben wir schon einige
leichen leider finden müssen in den
trümmern und wir werden davon ausgehen
müssen dass wir weitere tote finden
werden wir hoffen dass die zahl der
vermissten sich einfach reduziert auf
grund unserer kommunikationsprobleme das
ist unsere große hoffnung aber
wahrscheinlich sind wir noch nicht am
ende des schreckens angelangt verweigern
werden wir miteinander sprechen sehen
wir hinter ihnen die traktoren fahren
unermüdlich die ihren rettungseinsatz
dort leisten bei ihnen vielleicht können
sie uns noch ein bisschen was aus ihrer
persönlichen sicht geben auch harry
gleich ich weiß sie waren beide auch
selbst von der flutkatastrophe betroffen
verweigert wie haben sie das erlebt es
auch hier ihr haus selber betroffen
gewesen
steht zumindest was das haus angeht auf
der kippe aber im moment sind wir in
gedanken bei den vielen anderen menschen
meinen direkten nachbarn hat es
todesfälle gegeben
viele bekannte freunde nachbarn und das
geht uns allen so wir kennen uns gut im
aartal abend verluste zu beklagen kennen
familien die alles verloren haben hatten
teilweise selber alles verloren nachdem
sie oft 24 stunden oder länger in
todesangst darauf warten mussten ob sie
diese fluten auf dem hausdach aufbäumen
überleben
und insofern es ist eine schwierige
traumatische zeit
die leute stehen allerdings zusammen
dass sie auch hinter uns ist die
einsatzzentrale für die verbandsgemeinde
und die hilfe sowohl was feuerwehren
rettungsdienste die bundeswehr angeht
als auch die vielen privatleute die sich
organisieren und hier helfen und räumen
und machen und tun das tut sehr gut den
menschen das zu sehen aber es ist so
viel zerstört die haben es angedeutet es
wird jahre und jahrzehnte dauern und
werden milliarden brauchen und das muss
unkompliziert sein und das muss auch mit
logistischer unterstützung sein und mit
unterstützung von entsprechenden
arbeitsleistungen das können auch
normale firmen die hier ansässig werden
überhaupt von zeit und
personalkapazitäten stimmen also wir
brauchen hier schon viel unterstützung
darüber werden wir gleich noch mal
ausführlicher sprechen herr rauch sie
sind persönlich betroffen in leichlingen
auch bei ihnen steht das wasser jetzt
auch nicht die schwersten schäden nehme
ich an kein totaler hochwasser hotspot
und trotzdem haben auch sie ihre
erfahrung jetzt mit der flut machen
müssen na ja meine heimatstadt ist schon
schwer betroffen also die innenstadt
stand voll unter wasser und die menschen
haben in den letzten tagen alles
rausgetragen heute ist die ganze
innenstadt
obwohl das wasser weg ist gesperrt weil
alles abtransportiert werden muss und
das ist schon dramatisch wenn man sieht
wieder mit bulldozern mit krisen
radlagern das haus und alles was man im
hause weg und hoch oben auf einem
lastwagen beschmissen dürfen weg
gefahren wird ich selber kann mich nicht
beklagen bei mir ist wirklich nichts
wesentliches passiert aber hier gibt es
ganz viele menschen die irre viel
verloren haben und deswegen glaube ich
wird die erste wichtigste frage sein wie
können wir möglichst schnell und
irgendwo chaotisch helfen
das wird übrigens nicht einfach sein
weil wir geben steuergelder aus und das
kennt man ja
er wird dann nachher immer 37.000 mal
werden dann die besserwisser werde da
sein dass wir zu schnell und zu einfach
das geld ausgegeben haben ich kann ihnen
nur sagen ich hoffe dass wir in der
politik den mut haben wirklich ohne
große auflagen ohne großen
bürokratischen aufwand jetzt zu helfen
weil wir können es nicht nur wochenlang
warten das muss jetzt vorangehen
es gibt leute die haben nichts mehr
wir haben alles verloren das ist
manchmal sogar das haus verloren
das ist definitiv ihre verpflichtungen
im moment vor allen dingen gegenüber den
menschen in ihrer heimat aber eben auch
ganz besonders sind altena wo frau
weigand ich glaube ich kann das heute
sagen noch ja schockiert ist von dem was
da in den vergangenen tagen bei ihr
passiert ist in ihrer gemeinde
es gibt darüber möchte ich auch noch
kurz sprechen es gab viele meldungen
über plünderer haben sie selber solche
erfahrungen bei sich gemacht verweigert
also ich wohne in dem das wasser hat
sich langsam ist zum nachmittag des
nächsten tages zurückgezogen und am
abend hatten wir in unserem ort schon
die ersten plünderer
heute nachmittag hat es in diesem ort in
der ein versuchten geben am helllichten
tag da sind die leute geschnappt worden
das ist bei uns ein großes problem das
ist allerdings in der stadt bad neuenahr
ahrweiler und auch ein größeres problem
wo die geschäfte auch direkt nachdem
sich das hochwasser zurück und teilweise
auch skorpione sind das ist erschreckend
einerseits diese unglaubliche hilfe
diese unglaubliche solidarität von ganz
deutschland und andererseits dazwischen
diese menschen die diese unglaubliche
unvorstellbare not aus dass bei uns gab
es wirklich eine apokalypse
es steht kein stein auf dem anderen und
das in allen unseren orten
es ist nicht vorstellbar und es gibt
immer noch leute die das land ausnutzen
lassen sie uns über die warnungen
sprechen die es vorher gab vor dieser
katastrophe wann hatten sie auf ihrem
schreibtisch die erste warnung die
gesagt hat da kommt eine absolute
extremwetter situation auf sie zu ich
kann es nicht mehr genau wann ich glaube
es war anfang der woche waren wir über
den wetterdienst informiert das ist ja
dann auch automatisch weitergereicht
vorne anderen zuständigen behörden
also gewusst hat jeder das da war sowohl
zukommt wahrheit ist allerdings auch
dass man immer es immer schwerer wird
genau zu sagen wo wird die große menge
geld was darunter fallen also man hat
ein gefühl dafür in welchem region aber
das ist manchmal sehr eingegrenzt und
bei uns im bundesland war das auch noch
unterschiedlich auch total anders also
in arbeiter wir hatten die größten
probleme gerade in den mittelstädten
weil die kleinen flüsse das wasser nicht
gehalten haben und das kam nicht nur
durch starkregen sondern es kam dadurch
dass in den talsperren zu viel wasser
schon war und dafür noch viel drauf
haben und die das nicht gehalten haben
und dann musste wasser abgelassen werden
und das führt zum beispiel hier in
meiner stadt das ist super fließt hier
durch da war alles voll und die das war
auch dramatisch aber als dann die
flutwelle kamen da wackelt die ganze
stadt unter wasser und er nun aus vor
allen dingen das kommt dann ganz
plötzlich das hätte anders kommen können
also ich bin immer ich bin solange er
sie der politik dass ich einfach keine
lust mehr bob auf all die schlaumeier
die alles schon wohlsten
es ist leider ihre kompliziert und so
was hat bei der wupper zum beispiel seit
100 jahren nicht gegeben
das soll keine entschuldigung sein
sondern es ist einfach mal fakt und wir
werden natürlich nachzudenken haben wie
können wir warnsysteme noch verbessern
eine frage wie können wir auch die
menschen die jetzt keine nina app haben
trotzdem erreichen
es geht glaube ich nicht um schlaumeier
domherr all das muss ganz klar gesagt
werden und im nachhinein ist man
natürlich schlaue die frage ist was man
vorher wusste und was aus warnungen
geworden ist also vor allen dingen
internationale medien berichten ja heute
unter anderem der guardian oder die
sunday times wir können das auch mal
kurz zeigen es waren alle warnungen
und letztlich sind die aber nicht ernst
genug genommen wurden oder die
warnsysteme sind eben nicht aktiviert
worden
auch bei ihnen sollen diese meldung
geben am wochenende bereits davor
angekommen seien am samstag die sollen
dann konkretisiert worden seien am
montag nochmal auch durch den deutschen
wetterdienst und dann haben sie gerade
gesagt das ist dann weitergereicht
worden ist das vielleicht das problem
man hat daraus halt nicht direkt nach
handlung entwickelt passt mal auf so
einfach kann man das jetzt auch nicht
machen dann muss ich doch mal
widersprechen
wir sitzen ja nicht fröhlich herum und
haben langeweile sondern wir nehmen das
ernst und erreichen dass nicht weiter
das habe ich gesagt sondern es geht
natürlich mit klaren aufträgen weiter in
die struktur auf regierungspräsidenten
kommunen usw
und die sind die letzten
verantwortlichen die dann entscheiden
welche art von warnung wird ausgeworfen
sie sprechen mit einem innenminister der
2018 diese regel wieder eingeführt hat
ich hab sirenen übungstage gemacht haben
alle gedacht hätten knall weil sie
gedacht haben der krieg ist doch vorbei
was will der spinne eigentlich weil ich
begriffen habe dass wir neue
herausforderung bekommen
katastrophenfälle wasser sturm brände wo
wir menschen erreichen müssen und diese
idee mit modernen jeder hat doch nina
app ist ja auch nett aber unter uns
gesagt natürlich hat das nicht jeder
ältere menschen haben überhaupt kein
computer oder kein handy und der strom
ist einmal der strom ist ausgefallen
das handynetz das ausgefallene
vielerorts sofort auch das aber ja erst
nachher aber nachher zum teil ist also
nicht am anfang bei der warnung vorneweg
unter uns gesagt gilt das argument nicht
also lina etwa schon ein instrument das
zweite instrument sind sirenen die wir
ausbauen
wir haben über 5100 weiß ich wieviel
serien mittlerweile hier übrigens auch
im betrieb die probieren wir jedes jahr
gibt da einen wahn tag über das testen
weil ich glaube dass viele menschen ja
nicht mehr wissen wenn sirene läuft dass
das heißt das stört die einen sagen die
jugend da bloß rum die anderen sagen
kriege ist doch vorbei
die amtshaftung kite solcher probleme
das ist nicht nur eine frage an der
politik ich finde weigert lang befragen
lassen
verzeihung abholen müssen
wollte einmal frau weigern fragen weil
sie das mit den serien ja sehr
eindrücklich berichtet haben bei ihnen
in rheinland pfalz in altena gibt es
dort sirenen haben die sirenen geheult
in der nacht von mittwoch auf donnerstag
wenn die in der nacht von mittwoch auf
donnerstag geheult hätten
dann hätten sie keinen strom mehr gehabt
da war schon alles dabei es bedarf einer
guten katastrophenvorsorge ich glaube
viele leute waren gewarnt sie erinnern
sich wir hatten vor fünf jahren 20 16 an
der ein jahrhundert hochwasser das
jahrhunderthochwasser hatte hier in dem
ort altena den pegel von ungefähr drei
metern 70 wir haben jetzt hier unser
eigenes haus liegt ein meter fünfzig und
sehr geschätzt von diesen drei metern 70
noch und ob entfernt an unserem haus
stand das wasser geschätzt ungefähr
sechs meter hoch am ende vom zweiten
stock
dann können sie sich vorstellen das war
in der 1000 hochwasser das gab es war
eine katastrophe noch eine noch eine
nachfrage an henry der
katastrophenschutz würden sie zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt sagen er ist seine
aufgabe nachgekommen in diesen tagen
wenn wir über so viele tote sprechen und
der katastrophenschutz soll uns vor
katastrophen schützen ist er seine
aufgabe nachgekommen oder nicht ich kann
als nur für meinen - land ansprechen
woanders vielmehr jede information
ich glaube der katastrophenschutz wird
auch nicht 100 prozent sicherheit
organisieren
zweitens ich glaube dass die ihn in dem
katastrophenschutz tätig waren den
letzten tagen super gearbeitet haben und
dass die alles kinder gelegt haben was
hinzulegen war und rückens trotzdem
bleibt immer die frage wenn das dann
vorbei ist nachzudenken was kann man
noch besser machen
da bin ich aber hundertprozentig habe
noch nie erlebt dass irgendwann
irgendwas immer hundertprozentig schon
gut genug war
für uns wird das sind ansporn seiner
verpflichtung sein der notwendigkeit
seien einfach zu prüfen an welchen
stellen muss nachjustiert werden
ich glaube nur nicht dass die frage ist
wie viele system frage ist also ob man
das jetzt alles zentralistisch von
berlin aus steuern müsste und schon wäre
alles besser das glaube ich nicht
ich glaube dass gerade die stärke des
katastrophenschutzes darin liegt dass
die idee zentral ist dass sie viel
ehrenamtlichkeit hat damit ja ganz ganz
ganz viele leute hat die sich um ihre
eigene stadt bemühen weil sehr ihr
persönliches anliegen ist und trotzdem
ist in der frage der koordination
wahrscheinlich noch einiges zu tun aber
darüber haben wir ja auch in der
innenministerkonferenz wie es der böse
zufall will
vor kurzem waren noch lang und breit
diskutiert in dem fall wäre natürlich im
nachhinein angebracht gewesen so früh
wie möglich zu evakuieren frau weigern
nun wäre das sozusagen die ebene ihres
landrates gewesen ihres landratsamtes
gewesen dass diese entscheidung die sie
auch schwerwiegende entscheidung hätte
treffen müssen das heißt da kommen die
warnung rain man verfolgt die
pegelstände
und dann müssen sie in dem landratsamt
also nicht sie persönlich sondern auch
auf der ebene landrat diese
schwerwiegende entscheidung treffen die
möglicherweise auch kostspielige
entscheidung treffen wie haben sie das
an dem tag bei ihnen besprochen kam von
ihnen beispielsweise auch die bitte an
den landrat ruf den katastrophenfall aus
wir brauchen ihre hilfe das wird ganz
ganz schlimm oder wie sind sie damit
umgegangen
also es hat es hat sich abgezeichnet
dass die voraussagen dass der pegel
unter dem jahrhunderthochwasser und 2016
bleibt irgendwann nicht mehr gepasst
haben die flutwelle die dort bei uns
gekommen ist die iaa ist so schnell
gestiegen über das nie erlebt haben ja
ich habe versucht wie auch mit
sicherheit mehr leute versucht haben
dass der katastrophenfall ausgerufen
wird wann er tatsächlich ausgerufen
worden ist das dürfen sie mich nicht
fragen
ich habe es auch öfter angeregt ich
konnte die zahlen nicht glauben ich habe
mich durch das ganze land telefoniert um
die leute an das telefon zu bekommen die
die modelle rechnen für die pegelstände
und die haben ja wirklich bestätigt dass
auf einmal statt drei meter noch was
fünf meter fünfzig und nachher 750
dastand und das hat immer noch nicht
gepasst weil die den tatsächlich
gemessenen pegel kurve immer noch steil
angestiegen ist und irgendwann sind die
pegel gebrochen und wir sind alle nur
noch weiter aus den häusern raus die
leute halten sich auch ein normales
jahrhundert hochwasser eingestellt das
aber kann es zu der katastrophe und das
hätte auch gereicht um ist war
unvorstellbar dass uns aber hätte bei
ihnen evakuiert werden müssten frau
weigand
so
überrollt worden wäre dann würden die
menschen nicht mehr an diesem fluss
wohnen das was passiert ist ist
unvorstellbar und dafür hätte es keine
pläne geben können das ist ganz klar die
leute die bei normalen hochwasser
hochwasser in ihre häuser kriegen die
wissen dass gehen müssen und die sind
gegangen wir haben rechtzeitig die ganz
flachen mieter sprich unsere
campingplätze evakuiert wir haben andere
bereiche evakuiert aber das was dort
gekommen ist das war nicht denken
auch die haben alle waren her
großenteils in unseren holz die haben
gerade darum weigern das schicksal dann
festzustellen
derzeit verweigert sie haben gerade
gesagt dass es dann ganz lange dauerte
bis der katastrophenfall tatsächlich
ausgerufen wurde das heißt sie wollten
das tun und es hat stunden lang gedauert
bis der katastrophenfall tatsächlich
ausgerufen wurde wie lange
im land nachfragen ich kenne auch die
mechanismen nicht wissen wir waren alle
verzweifelt wir haben gesehen es gibt
mindestens dieses jahrhundert hochwasser
das war eindeutig ist wollte immer mehr
und den rest der geschichte kenne ich
nicht weil ich 11.000 menschen haben den
boden und von denen wohl unter 8.000 an
diesem schluss und ich habe gesehen was
da auf uns zugekommen ist und irgendwann
habe ich nur unseren pfarrer noch gut
als eines der letzten sachen und feucht
das rathaus van basten unsere menschen
um zu beten für ihre menschen ich danke
ihnen für das gespräch verweigern frau
henry möchte ich noch einmal fragen weil
es da um die verschiedenen
verwaltungsebenen geht und ich empfinde
das jetzt so sagen es ist gut dass
dezentral zu überlassen weil die
menschen natürlich ihre region kennen
das ist total nachvollziehbar
gleichzeitig ist es so eine große
entscheidung die man zu treffen hat
können dass ihrem ihrem empfinden nach
in solchen drucksituationen wo es auch
um so viel spezialwissen geht können
dass landräte kann man das auf dieser
ebene so wichtige weitreichende
entscheidungen zu treffen wie sie dort
beispielsweise in ahrweiler getroffen
werden mussten an dem tag möglicherweise
ganze orte innerhalb weniger kürzester
zeit zu evakuieren können die eine
solche schwerwiegende weitreichende
entscheidung treffen kommt erstens immer
auf die menschen an die da sitzen
im prinzip ja also ich kenne bei uns
keine situation wo das nicht
funktioniert hat das problem war
übrigens selten aber bei uns wenn ich
das mal an deuten darf das entscheidung
getroffen worden sind jetzt wird
evakuiert sondern die realisierung weil
die menschen das natürlich als ein zu
recht als einen ungeheuren eingriff in
ihre privatsphäre sehen und sich
geweigert haben oder so getan haben als
würden sie weg gehen und sind dann doch
wieder gekommen
also das ist schon noch ein problem denn
die letzte spiel letzte stufe die dann
ein greif wäre dass wir mit hilfe von
polizei menschen zwangsweise rausholen
das haben wir gott sei dank bisher nicht
machen müssen aber das ist eine verdammt
spannende also spannende politische
frage ob man das macht und ich war an
der staumauer in steinbach und das im
5000 leute die dahinter wurden die jetzt
evakuiert worden sind
wir haben die örtlichen vertreter gesagt
wir glauben sie nicht dass sie alle weg
gegangen sind und meinen hinweis ja da
müsste man das mit vom polizei
organisieren kommt dann der antwort
darauf haben sie in der ort wo sie 5000
leute hinstellen können diesen
festgenommen haben also da sind noch ein
paar fragen offen garantiert die über
die man auch ganz klug nachdenkt muss
ich will es nur eben nicht in der hektik
des moments machen weil wir haben jetzt
so viel erste baustellen zu erledigen
und da muss eins nach dem anderen
sorgfältig jetzt abgearbeitet werden wie
viel wurde denn in nordrhein westfalen
evakuiert als die flut begann also
nachher sie haben jetzt ein beispiel
genannt wo eben man sieht dass die
talsperre vor voll läuft davon eine
gefahr ausgeht aber haben sie vorher
ganze ortschaften evakuieren lassen nein
nach meinem kenntnisstand so kann doch
sein dass ich jetzt was über sie im
moment nein warum auch nicht weil es gar
nicht notwendig war hat sich ja auch
gezeigt es waren nur dann notwendig wo
dann bei den talsperren eine solche
sondersituation entstand oder das war
jetzt erbstadt wo einfluss sich so
entwickelt hat dass plötzlich eine
dramatische situation da war da ist aber
in den allermeisten fällen auch
rechtzeitig evakuiert worden
und wenn nicht haben wir ganz schnell
die leute da von den dächern runter
geholt wir hatten dankenswerterweise der
riesigen unterstützung auch von
bundeswehr und bundespolizei und das ist
nicht immer hundertprozentig exakt
voraus sie war also bisher bisher total
glaube ich war das über cruise problem
nicht das größte problem
letzte frage noch an sie herr
innenminister wir hatten noch heute ihr
ministerium und arme antworten gebeten
bezüglich der warnung die es vorher gab
und ihr ministerium hat auch mit dem
satz geantwortet wir zeigen das morgen
auch auf seite 4 im bild das sei ein
ereignis gewesen dass absehbar war
gleichzeitig ein solches ereignis war
abzusehen so lautet der satz und
gleichzeitig sagen sie auch dass die
hilfs oder wahn systeme im großen und
ganzen funktioniert haben auch die
evakuierungen hätte es nicht mehr geben
sollen
das heißt wo es genau jetzt der fehler
im system wenn wir über 150 über 150
tote insgesamt sprechen den nordrhein
westfalen und rheinland pfalz ja ich
kann dir nur bei 46 in nur zwei jahren
reden und die sind ganz unterschiedliche
situationen
es gab situationen wo menschen nicht
darauf geachtet haben
es gab situationen wo feuerwehrleute im
einsatz gestorben sind
da hilft auch keine warnung um ein
beispiel zu nennen und es gab
situationen wo sie nicht rechtzeitig wo
sie sorgen auch nicht ernst genommen
haben ich kann der frau bürgermeisterin
ja nur zustimmen ich glaube ganz viele
menschen haben die gefahren die da
entstehen sind auch noch nicht so
richtig verinnerlicht hallo ich glaube
da ist übrigens auch eine riesenaufgabe
aufklärerisch tätig zu sein klingt jetzt
so banal aber es ist nicht ganz
unwichtig ich habe ganz viele leute
jetzt erlebt die sagen ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen können als ich da stand und
das wasser der wupper sei so was gibt es
da überhaupt nicht doch das gibt es und
das kann es noch mal geben
ja genau deshalb muss man wenn
staatliche institutionen hinweise geben
warnungen aussprechen sirenen anstellen
oder feuerwehrleute mit dem
feuerwehrwagen durch die städte fahren
mit lautsprechern dann muss man auch
bereit sein sich darauf einzulassen aber
das ist glaube ich zu früh das
abschließend zu bewerten aber die
vorläufige bilanz ist jetzt wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden habe im großen und
ganzen hat eigentlich alles funktioniert
da würde ich niemals sagen dann wir
jetzt keine toten geben dürfen
es kann nicht alles hundertprozentig
funktioniert haben aber es hat nicht so
schlecht dass es gab nach meinem
heutigen der kenntnisstand noch keine
großen grundsätzlichen probleme aber es
gab garantiert auch in einzelfällen
sachen die kann man aber jetzt nicht
punkten die muss man sieht man erst wenn
man jeden fall sich genau anschaut und
das werden wir machen das werden wir
machen müssen weil man aus fehlern
lernen muss aber wer arbeitet das jetzt
richtig auf herold die frage stellt sich
mir schon wir befinden uns ja in einem
nicht ganz unwichtigen
bundestagswahlkampf auch alle parteien
alle vertreter
da natürlich mit sozusagen gefangen in
rheinland pfalz sind dass spd und fdp
und grüne und bei ihnen ist das
natürlich die cdu und die fdp das heißt
im grunde im sinne der bürger müssten
alle ein großes ein riesiges interesse
haben dass in den nächsten wochen in den
nächsten monaten auf zu arbeiten können
sie versprechen dass das passiert ich
verspreche dass ich für meinen teil das
tue
ob alle mitmachen kann ich nicht
versprechen ich kann nicht für andere
versprechen ich bin bei ihnen dass das
offen
am besten eine antwort ist die immer
nicht parteipolitischem streit löst
sondern mit hoher gemeinsamkeit ich
hoffe darauf ich finde mich darum
bemühen das ist auch wahr
ob das schnell geht das es wird fragen
geben die hat man schnell gelöst und es
wird fragen geben die nicht schwierig zu
lösen zum beispiel bei der ard statt
dass der fluss dann die chance dieses
dieser kiesgrube ergreift ist logisch
also wenn da ein ganz viel wasser kommt
da bis dahin wohl der tiefpunkt ist und
dadurch ist das problem entstanden hätte
diese kiesgrube da nicht gegeben oder
diese anschwellen also nur man muss da
aufpassen was war die ursache was war
die wirkung welche bedingungen verändern
ich glaube zum beispiel ist doch
interessant dass wir bei den großen
flüssen die sicherung mittlerweile auch
technisch so ein eingriff sollte man nie
sagen aber so weit getrieben haben dass
wir da größere schäden in den letzten
jahren haben vermeiden können
bei den kleinen füßen sind wir
offensichtlich darauf nicht so gut
vorbereitet ich finde die hauptaufgabe
der zukunft ist jetzt wie sieht
hochwasserschutz in diesen gebieten aus
wo die kleinen und mittleren flüsse sind
haben wir da genug getan was kann man da
auf neues tool gibt es vielleicht
technische möglichkeiten was ist mit dem
planungsrecht zu tun wo bauen wir unsere
häuser hin also dass es sind ganz viele
fragen und auch mal die so in ein paar
wochen bei ihm hinhaut es gibt leute die
machen das ich kann den sand ich nicht
bei mir wert hat gründlich gemacht und
wenn es länger dauert es länger
die zeit ist nicht mein argument mein
argument ist dass es richtig ist was am
ende haben damit vor konsequenzen ziehen
die vernünftig sind fürs nächste mal so
weigand letzte frage an sie und
verbundene auch mit dem spendenaufruf
denn darum haben sie uns gebeten und das
machen wir ganz ganz gerne es gibt ein
eigenes spendenkonto für sie in
ahrweiler für die hilfe in altena das
heißt sie alle die uns zu schauen
aktuell bei bild und das in den nächsten
stunden noch tun werden auf unserer
website auf bild.de
und sie überlegen wie sie hilfen erde
helfen wollen aktuell sie können das in
altena sie können dort helfen in den
besonders betroffenen gebieten zum
beispiel in rheinland pfalz das ist eine
möglichkeit sie sehen cornelia weigern
die firma bürgermeisterin die so
eindrucksvoll geschildert hat wie schwer
ihr ort ihre gemeinde in altena
getroffen wurde wenden sie sich also
gerne an diese kontonummer in bei der
kreissparkasse in ahrweiler frau weigand
wann rechnen sie damit dass ja irgendwie
wieder normales leben bei ihnen in
altona möglich sein wird und glauben sie
dass ihre gemeinde irgendwann wieder so
aussehen wird wie vor der flut
es ist kaum denkbar zur zeit wann das
der fall sein wird
es ist klar dass unsere gemeinden die so
stark betroffen sind mit sicherheit
danach anders aussehen bei viele der
gebäude die prägend waren die dort über
50 100 oder 150 jahre gestanden haben
abgerissen werden müssen
wir hoffen dass es eine zukunft gibt
weil die frage ist wer zieht da wieder
hin wo ein jahrhunderthochwasser um den
faktor drei überstiegen wird das ist
nicht rechnen war das ist nicht denkbar
das ist nicht planbar das ist das eine
und das andere ist unsere infrastruktur
ist weg unsere brücken unsere straßen
unsere bahn
all das ist zerstört und bei uns muss
die infrastruktur wieder aufgebaut
werden dafür brauchen wir wirklich
unbürokratisch finanzielle unterstützung
ob da jetzt bundeswehr mit arbeitet da
muss was gebaut werden das übersteigt
unsere vorstellungskraft und davon hängt
es auch ab wie lange das dauern wird ob
diese mittel in dieser menge fließen wie
das dort gebraucht wir hoffen sehr die
leute unterstützen sich viele sind auch
die zukunft ausgerichtet aber vielleicht
trauen sich auch manche nicht mehr wenn
dieses tal ist sehen wir hatten eine
undenkbare naturkatastrophe und ich
glaube in diesen dimensionen kann man
nicht denken sonst wird man in solchen
tendenzen das weitergehen wir stehen
hier alle unter schock
lassen sie uns die zeit zum atmen im
moment denken wir noch kontakt zu tag
finden die immer noch überlebende
was können wir jetzt sichern dann geht
es von tag zur woche bekommen wir strom
bekommen wir wasser was wie geht's
weiter können wir häuser retten müssen
wir abreißen wir sind noch gar nicht so
weit wirklich an die zukunft zu denken
natürlich muss das parallel laufen und
gab ihnen ganz herzlich für das gespräch
frau weigand nach altena heroin beiden
das ist dunkel geworden
danke dass sie sicher auch so lange den
fragen gestellt haben danke herzlich und
ihnen von herzen wirklich alles gute in
diese flutgebiete wir haben auch hier ja
fast ein schlechtes gewissen gehabt im
trockenen zu stehen in berlin und haben
ganz wahnsinnig das kann ich für uns
alle hier sagen mitgefühlt mit ihnen und
bitte lassen sie uns wissen alles was
wir tun können für sie im moment das
wollen wir unbedingt versuchen danke
ihnen und mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
habe ich heute auch die gelegenheit
gehabt zu sprechen am nachmittag haben
wir das gespräch aufgezeichnet und ich
habe ihn auch gefragt was denn
der katastrophenschutz möglicherweise
falsch gemacht hat denn wenn es so viele
tote gibt in einer solchen katastrophe
dann muss doch etwas schief gelaufen
sein das was hier anders waren was neu
war war einfach dass es zu dieser
jahreszeit so unerwartet kam dass die
menschen nicht stunden oder tage hatten
sich vorzubereiten
auch darüber wird man reden müssen haben
wir ausreichend vorsorge getroffen um
solche ereignisse rechtzeitig zu
erkennen
die diskussion läuft ja auch bereits das
muss geklärt werden nicht im sinne von
schuldzuweisungen sondern um auch in
anderen teilen von deutschland
rechtzeitig sicherstellen zu können dass
die gefährdung von menschen minimiert
wird
wir erleben heute dass in bayern und in
österreich und den anderen orten
ähnliche ereignisse sich abspielen
und das ist glaube ich ein wichtiger
ratschlag an warnsignal für uns alle
warum so viele tot haben sie für sich da
annähernd eine antwort gefunden ich
glaube es wäre falsch zu spekulieren
ohne konkrete antworten zu kennen
ich bin als wirtschaftsminister ganz
sicherlich nicht der spezialist und
katastrophenschutz und deshalb sage ich
wir müssen das sehr genau aufarbeiten um
für die zukunft auch lehren ziehen zu
können kann es überhaupt sein dass wenn
so viele menschen sterben bei einer
solchen katastrophe dass man dann sagen
kann die warnsysteme unser
katastrophenschutz die sind auf modernen
stand das hat alles funktioniert ich
glaube das haben wir nicht gesagt
sondern ich habe eben ganz deutlich
gesagt es muss sobald wir die
unmittelbare hilfe geleistet haben die
jetzt im vordergrund steht auch geschaut
werden gibt es dinge die nicht gut
gelaufen sind gibt es dinge die schief
gelaufen sind und da muss korrigiert
werden
es geht nicht um schuldzuweisungen es
geht um verbesserungen für die zukunft
und das müssen aber diejenigen machen
die nah an den ereignissen sind die auch
die erkenntnisse in der sache haben also
metereologe beispielsweise
katastrophenschutz einrichtungen die
müssen sich zusammensetzen ich habe
keinen zweifel dass das geschehen wird
wir haben einen großartigen
katastrophenschutz das thw für das ich
staatssekretär einigen jahre lang mit
zuständig war hat einen grandiosen job
gemacht die feuerwehren ebenso wenn wir
diese freiwilligen organisationen nicht
gehabt hätten wäre die zahl der opfer
und die zahl der schäden wahrscheinlich
sehr viel größer geworden
also auch der bundeswirtschaftsminister
peter altmaier sagt das muss
aufgearbeitet werden was hier im
katastrophenschutz schief gelaufen ist
in den vergangenen tagen darüber wollen
wir weiter diskutieren mit dieser runde
jetzt nämlich mit jürgen trittin mit
béla anda dem früheren
regierungssprecher von gerhard schröder
mit gerd friedsam dem thw chefin mit
enormen wirbel der selbst mit angepackt
hat und gerettet geholfen hat in den
vergangenen tagen in allen schönen guten
abend herr trittin bleiben wir einmal
anfangs bei dieser frage des
katastrophenschutzes ich habe das gerade
schon versucht dem gespräch
herauszufinden wenn es so viele tote
gibt bei einer katastrophe kann man dann
überhaupt sagen hier hat alles
funktioniert
nein man kann dich einfach zur
tagesordnung übergehen aber ich glaube
ein teil der antwort hat verweigern die
bürgermeisterin von halte nachgegeben
es hat warnungen gegeben es hat
erkenntnisse gegeben dass wir vor einer
erneuten jahrhundertflut den mak
daraufhin sind bestimmte bereiche
evakuiert worden
gottseidank sonst hätte ist
möglicherweise noch mehr tote gegeben
und dann hat sich der katastrophe in
einer weise entwickelt das das dreifache
des letzten jahrhundert hochwassers
eingetreten ist und das was wir als
konsequenz daraus ziehen müssen ist dass
wir auch die möglichkeit solcher
eskalation kommen wird ich besser
vorbereitet sind wir haben 2002 nach der
flut an der elbe ein hochwasserschutz
gesetz man auf den weg gebracht was zum
beispiel die bautätigkeit in gebieten
von jahrhunderthochwasser sehr
eingeschränkt hat manche hätten sich
sogar mehr dabei gewünscht aber wir
müssen heute uns hinstellen und
tatsächlich überlegen was sind dann die
region die von einem jahrhundert
hochwasser betroffen sind diese karten
müssen nach dieser katastrophe neu
gezeichnet werden
das heißt in diesen gebieten kann dann
weniger neu gebaut werden wir müssen
zweitens in den engen tälern
stimme ich an rolle ja zu uns technische
möglichkeiten eröffnen solche mengen von
wasser im zweifelsfall auch schneller
durch live zu können und drittens wir
müssen die rückhalte fähigkeiten die wir
in der landschaft haben
das ist das komplizierteste überhaupt
die rückseite fähigkeiten wieder massiv
erhöhen retentionsflächen
überschwemmungsflächen ist in solchen
theater sehr sehr schwierig aber das ist
die eigentliche herausforderung vor der
bestehen und über eine der gründe ist
warum damals 2002 von den 6,5 milliarden
die zur verfügung gestellt worden sind
vier schnell abgeflossen ist aber all
die mittel die für rückbau und öffnet
von da ist beispielsweise vorgesehen
sind sehr langsam abgeschlossen weil das
sehr schwierig zu vermitteln ist gerade
wenn das hochwasser land wieder gesunken
ist mich hat einsatz bilder anderer
langjähriger regierungssprecher von
gerhard schröder mich hat einsatz gerade
von herbert reul ein bisschen aufgeregt
nämlich die warnung waren ja alle da das
hat er auch bestätigt zumindest ein
anfang der woche
und dann hat man die weitergegeben und
das ist genau mein eindruck bisher die
lage irgendwie alle auf den tisch man
wusste das wäre eine extreme
wettersituation vielleicht konnte man
nicht ganz genau vorhersagen die
pegelstände aber wenn man sich jetzt die
warnungen anschaut die da ab samstag
sonntag montag kam zunächst von inter
nationalen wetterdiensten und daneben
auch vom deutschen wetterdienst die
waren schon die sehr sehr präzise die
haben sogar genauer gesagt für hagen für
wuppertal für altena und so weiter und
so fort da waren auch pegelstände schon
dabei also das heißt war das problem man
hat diese wetterwarnung so weitergegeben
und dann versandten die irgendwo in der
verwaltung weil da kommen halt alle
naselang unwetterwarnung und man weiß
nicht so ganz genau was macht sie jetzt
damit wird schon alles gutgehen
gerade jemand schlimme fehler gemacht
aber das hat er dann auch gemerkt hat
wer dann im zweiten abschnitt dann ihres
gesprächs sky versucht es geradezurücken
hatte gedanken gesagt ein eines wurden
nicht nur weitergegeben sondern hat
bemüht zu erklären was dann getan wurde
was konkret dann daraus folgt aber das
muss man hinterfragen wo es nur
weitergegeben und nicht gehandelt oder
was da geschehen und das hat auch nichts
mit wahlkampf zu tun sondern das würde
jeder in einer solchen situation
hinterfragen sie haben es gerade das war
ein thema international heute überall
ist darüber berichtet worden in großen
britischen medien auch wie das zum teil
auf gemacht haben und nun klären gab es
diese warnungen und was ist daraus
erfolgt herfried thw chef sie sind
selbst aus der region altena
beziehungsweise haben da lange lange
gelebt sie kennen das also gut sie
können die örtlichkeiten dort gut sind
auch familiär sogar stark betroffen ich
weiß dass die familie ihrer schwester
gerettet wurde über ein hubschrauber per
hubschrauber gerettet wurde zum glück
aus dieser region wenn sie jetzt wissen
für all das gab es warnungen hat haben
die sie möglicherweise sogar erreicht
vorher beim thw also kannten sie solche
natürlich sind wir sozusagen
angeschlossen an nationale und
internationale vorfahren systeme die in
der tat auch diese starkregen ereignisse
voraus gesagt haben da steht natürlich
in erster linie die vorbereitung einer
katastrophenschutzorganisation des thws
im vordergrund zu sensibilisieren und zu
sagen wir müssen uns letzten endes auf
eine aber eine hochwassersituation
einstellen die aufgrund dieser
starkregen ereignisse einstellt
eintreten kann
und das wie gesagt ist natürlich auch
für die regionen in nordrhein westfalen
und eben im nördlichen bereich von
rheinland pfalz auch der fall gewesen
einsatzkräfte deren aufgabe ist es dann
so zu sagen ob dieser basis
zuschauen dass die mittel die man dazu
braucht auch den hohen grad der
einsatzbereitschaft der
einsatzbereitschaft haben
es ist natürlich und gesagt insofern
kann ich das aus eigener anschauung so
ein stück weit auch beurteilen
im grunde an diesem sozusagen an diesem
mittwochabend hat sich diese situation
so eskaliert wo man auch persönlich
sagen kann damit hast du eigentlich so
nicht rechnen nicht gerechnet
und natürlich ist man nicht nur mit den
einsatzkräften nur noch mit der familie
letzten endes verbunden und bespricht
dort entsprechende vorsorgemaßnahmen und
das ist letzten endes zu einer rettung
gekommen ist vom dachfirst sozusagen des
eigenen hauses das ist schon eine
situation die ich so wenn dieser in
dieser form so weder porto bruchteil
habe noch so erwartet haben aber ich
will das noch einmal auf den punkt
bringen mit ihnen dem thw chef selbst
dem nordrhein westfälischen
innenminister herbert reul läuft
sozusagen der keller voll
selbst bei ihm zu hause in seinem
heimatort ist wirklich land unter das
hat er gerade nochmal geschildert
selbst bei dem thw chef von deutschland
wird die familie vom dach gerettet und
dann heißt es anschließend es gab aber
warnung das heißt irgendwas ist ja aus
diesen warnungen in dieser zeit passiert
möglicherweise hat man die nicht ernst
genug genommen oder man hatte einfach
nicht die mittel um diese warnung ja
richtig ernst zu nehmen um um die
entsprechenden vorkehrungen zu treffen
was ist ihre wahrheit herr friedsam
meine wahl ist dass dieses ausmaß
aufgrund dieser starkregen ereignisse
so nicht vorauszusehen war und das muss
man dazu sind uns auch konstatieren dass
man da möglicherweise auch selber die
situation nicht richtig erkannt aber
verzeihung noch einmal ganz kurz
nachgefragt weil der deutsche
wetterdienst und ich glaube das feld
nicht in diesem bereich schlaumeier tun
der sagt halt und kann ja verweisen auf
seine warnung doch doch der hat das
genau gesagt am montag der hat genau das
vorhergesagt mit genau den regenmengen
mit genau für genau diese region
friedsam dies kann also ich kann an
dieser stelle nur sagen meine
einschätzung war diejenige zu sagen okay
wir haben es hier mit einer haben es
hier mit einer außergewöhnlichen
situation zu tun bekommen aber letzten
endes dieses ausmacht dreimal so stark
wie alles das was bisher da gewesen ist
war aus meiner sicht so nicht zu viel
wirbel ich weiß wie sehr sie angepackt
haben wie sehr sie geholfen haben wie
viele menschen sie in den vergangenen
tagen gerettet haben sagen sie ganz kurz
haben sie vorher ein bewusstsein dafür
gehabt da kommt was ganz schlimmes in
unserer region auch von zu haben sie die
sirenen gehört usw
auf gar keinen fall dass das weil man
hat hier regen gehabt man hat den regen
gesehen er war die ganze zeit da ja es
war stark aber dass das in dem ausmaß
passiert dass das hat keiner auf dem
schirm gehabt also auf gar keinen fall
spielt auch schlafen gegangen und nichts
ahnend lang von morgens aus strobo ohne
ohne alles und irgendwann geht das handy
wieder an und man kommen nachricht man
sieht bilder und man denkt das ist jetzt
hier alles ein schlechter scherz
aber ja das war wie im kriegsgebiet
nachher danach das heißt sie haben
vorher im grunde gar nichts davon gehört
sei es im radio im fernsehen keine
entsprechenden warnungen bekommen und
bei ihnen gibt es auch keine
lautsprecherwagen
und also es war jetzt nicht so dass sie
gesagt haben ja ja kommt bleibt es mir
weg mit euren warnung das wird schon
alles gutgehen
nein ich sitze jetzt auch nicht den
ganzen tag da und höre mir die
wetterberichte an man hat das schon
mitgekriegt man hat sich auch gesehen es
hat hier gefühlt die letzten zwei wochen
durchgehend einsparungs geregnet und ich
waren der boden war gesättigt vom ganzen
wasser und das heißt es vom starkregen
das war schon bekannt aber man hat das
jetzt nicht einfach so wahrgenommen als
warnung auf gar keinen fall oder als
bitte verlassen sie alle regionen wo
überhaupt die aa fliesst oder rhein
fließt das oft gar keinen fall das hat
keiner hier wahrgenommen sonst denke ich
während die ausmaße würden von den
menschen leben nicht so dramatisch
geworden
wir haben sie selbst den einsatz von thw
feuerwehr erlebt na ja wir haben für
morgens alle unsere autos mit allem was
wir hatten bestückt aggregaten pumpen
etc 3 und sind dann halt haben probiert
da in das krisengebiet zu fahren was wir
da machen konnten und dann irgendwann
standen wir da hinten drin war für
dieses der covers gemacht hatten und das
war im endeffekt hast du gedacht du bist
in einem kriegsgebiet nur ohne panzer es
war unbeschreiblich die die ersten
etagen also das erdgeschoss in ganz
kreis bad neuenahr ahrweiler ist weg da
steht nichts mehr da sind das alles
weggespült worden autos fliegen kurz und
kreuz und quer durch die gegend katerna
kein gebe keine fahrbahn mehr dass das
war unvorstellbar das ist dass das kennt
man sonst nur aus dem fernsehen aber
nicht live und nicht in diesem ausmaß
nicht dass städte verschwinden teilweise
ahrweiler die hoch unfassbar das ist so
groß dass kann sich normalerweise gar
nicht vorstellen eigentlich viele andere
als die ersten dieser bilder vor allen
dingen aus der luft kam am
donnerstagmorgen da ging es mir ehrlich
gesagt genauso also das sind bilder die
man so aus dem ausland kannte aus
bestimmten gebieten auch in den usa vor
allen dingen war aus asien das
dannhäuser zusammenstürzen wirklich wie
pappkartons ganze region plattgemacht
sind vom wasser die häuser alle wie
gesagt rein weise nur noch in trümmer
verwandelt sind usw
würden sie sagen der katastrophenschutz
nach ihrer einschätzung jetzt ein paar
tage nach beginn dieser fluten hat
seinen namen verdient der schützt
wirklich die bevölkerung jetzt werden
könnte das treffen schutz hat wirklich
gerne alles getan was möglich war und
ihm geht es um vorwürfe machen aus
meiner warte heraus wissen wir hier im
trockenen sitzen und im warmen bett das
wäre wirklich billig weil ich bin in der
nähe von der ahr groß geworden in bonn
und ich war da oft nicht wirklich die
kinder zusammen wenn ich das sehe und
bin ich cornelia war kannte und auch den
innenminister von nrw aber das ist
wirklich furchtbar und alltag von
menschen sehen
also insofern wenig darf aus dieser
warte aus keinem einen vorwurf machen
das muss aufgeklärt werden was da
schiefgelaufen ist und sicherlich ich
meine jugendtrainers erwähnt seit 2002
ist viel getan worden
den hochwasserschutz gesetz auf den weg
gebracht worden massiv geld gegeben
worden da haben eine steuersenkung
verschoben
ich denke solche anstrengungen sollte es
geben und nicht nur schöne bilder oder
schreckliche bilder sondern eben
entsprechend dann auch tatsächlich
handlung und ich denke da kommt man hier
nicht aber diejenigen den
katastrophenschutz gearbeitet haben
wir haben wirklich ihr menschen
möglichstes getan und sich noch mehr ich
will dir noch einen o ton zeigen heute
eine aussage vom rheinland-pfälzischen
innenminister roger lewentz der hat sich
heute so geäußert bei seinem besuch mit
der ministerpräsidentin und mit der
kanzlerin in schuld man hat noch sehr
schnell versucht zu reagieren
allerdings war das eine moment explosion
des wassers das muss man so sagen
und da können sie die allerbesten
vorsorge und waren situation haben wenn
waren gerätschaften zerstört sind mit
gebäuden weggerissen werden dann ist das
eine sehr schwierige situation aber ich
war abends schon in der technischen
einsatzleitung wir haben sehr sehr
schnell sehr schnell sehr viel hilfe
herbei geführt aber ein ereignis das
mitten in der nacht stattfindet wird es
mit einsetzen der helligkeit auch
überhaupt ansatzweise überschaubarer ein
ereignis das mitten in der nacht
stattfindet trittin ist dass in
deutschland ein zusätzliches
leben wenn sich ein hochwasser nicht an
dienstzeiten hält das tut ein hochwasser
nie aber nochmal wie bürgermeisterin hat
zu recht darauf hingewiesen dass man mit
den erfahrungen die man ja immer teil
gemacht hat und ich kenne das ja auch
aus der zeit in bonn
so eine der schönsten touren die man
machen konnte man vor mit dem rad über
den hart bag-urteil und dann den rhein
wieder hoch es ist alles total in
trümmern mein bruder war gestern da es
ist wirklich schrecklich was da passiert
ist trotzdem mann war vorbereitet man
hat bestimmte schritte gemacht man hat
bestimmte bereiche evakuiert man hat
aber nicht damit gerechnet dass das in
dieser konkreten situation an diesem ort
zu dieser größe aufläuft und jetzt nützt
es nichts kurzfristig und kurzatmig über
einzelne technische versagen zu reden
die hat es mit sicherheit gegeben wie
immer bei solchen katastrophen sondern
wir müssen uns darüber gedanken machen
wie wir künftig für solche katastrophen
besser uns schützen um schützen lassen
das wird ein sehr schwieriger und
übrigens ein sehr konfliktreicher
vielleicht gar nicht mal zunächst teurer
aber ein sehr konfliktreicher weg weil
es immer darum geht dass man dem wasser
mehr raum geben muss wenn man wasser
mehr raum gibt ist weniger raum für
siedlungs infrastrukturen ähnlichem da
das ist das problem und der konflikt mit
dem wir uns auseinandersetzen müssen und
ansonsten ich finde zum teil was die
menschen im katastrophenschutz gemacht
haben das kann man gar nicht hoch genug
loben mein thw aus götting räumt gerade
in wuppertal auf die sind dann darüber
gefahren und dann ist eine organisation
die unglaublich was leistet eilig und
ich finde sie sollte das sollte an
dieser stelle auch mal gesagt dass teile
ich heute so auf diesen punkt rum weil
mein eindruck garde war vor allen dingen
nach dem gespräch mit frau weigern dass
es eben eine gewisse behäbigkeit eine
gewisse trägheit in solchen momenten
gibt sie hat stundenlang versucht
jemanden im landratsamt zu erreichen der
dafür zuständig ist und dann dauerte das
und dauerte das so dauerte das obwohl
sie den katastrophenfall aus rufen
wollte und es dauerte noch mal sechs
sieben acht stunden bis das genau
passierte aber um auf ihren punkt zu
kommen
trittin mit dem das wasser braucht mehr
raum das bedeutet ja in diesen orten man
muss die menschen umsiedeln das sind ja
keine neubaugebiete dort unten an der
ahr zumindest größtenteils dies da jetzt
getroffen hat sondern das sind ja ganz
gewachsene orte teilweise der ortskern
der eben unten liegt ganz alte
fachwerkhäuser auch in anderen städten
haben wir das in den vergangenen tagen
gesehen bad münstereifel zum beispiel
schwerst getroffen fachwerkhäuser die
menschen müsste man umsiedeln
sie brauchen maßnahmen sie können zum
teil vor den orten müssen sie mehr
fläche schaffen weil wir nicht alles
umsiedeln weil wir diese historischen
stadtkern und ortskerne
das sind wunderschöne landschaft müssen
winzer die da arbeiten und so das kann
man doch nicht alles weg machen aber man
wird möglicherweise auch spuren schlagen
müssen damit wasser schneller durchläuft
es kann sein dass diese breiten spuren
90 tage 90 prozent der zeit ungenutzt
sind und sogar trocken fallen aber für
diesen einen fall müssen sie dann zur
verfügung stellen das ist die
herausforderung der man steht aber das
muss man dann für jeden ort punkt für
punkt im einzelnen durch buchstabieren
das kann man nicht im grünen tisch und
auch nicht ganz zentral regeln da bin
ich ganz froh über den förderalismus den
wir haben
der wirbel welches bild welche besondere
erfahrungen der letzten tage bleibt
ihnen wohl für immer im kopf aber zwei
viele menschen die gar nicht mehr wissen
wohin sollen die nichts mehr haben das
haus zerstört vielleicht gar nicht
versichert ja entsetzlich keiten das ist
einfach ich bin jetzt jung mit 40 jahren
seit ich jetzt mal ich hätte nie gedacht
dass über krieg mit leben erleben muss
das war wie krieg halt ohne ohne panzer
das geht eigentlich einfach so aus dem
kopf dass das kann ich glaube ich nicht
das bleibt auch für längere zeit drin
dass das wird auch weiterhin so aus den
bei uns also ich glaube auch nicht dass
das ein zweiter drei monaten gegessen
ist da dass das wird über jahre gehen
der wiederaufbau wenn ich wenn nicht
noch länger die gesamte infrastruktur
ist da komplett zerstört damit meine ich
jetzt nicht nur häuser und straßen
wenn ich gas wasser kanal
das braucht man nicht nur zwei minuten
wieder auf egal wer da kommt so viel so
viel manpower ist gar nicht vorhanden so
dass es wahnsinn da ist eine ganze stadt
verschwunden er friedsam wie viel
manpower haben sie noch nach diesen
wahnsinnig anstrengenden stunden für sie
und ihre helfer ihre auch ehrenamtlichen
helfer wie viel kraft haben sie noch und
worauf richten sie sich ein auf den
marathon und ich denke wir haben noch
eine sehr große durchhaltefähigkeit wir
sind derzeit etwa mit 2500 kräften im
einsatz die auch turnusgemäß abgelöst
werden und es stehen ja auch sozusagen
jetzt im bezug beendung der
menschenrettung auch alle themen auf der
tagesordnung wie kriegt man den menschen
wieder trinkwasser beispielsweise zur
verfügung gestellt die kann man in
bestimmten bereichen wo die
stromversorgung tatsächlich so in
mitleidenschaft getreten ist
unterstützung machen und da haben wir
noch eine ein breites spektrum an
unterstützungsmöglichkeiten und ich kann
das an dieser stelle einfach nur noch
mal sagen auch denen gegenüber die in
den kommunen und den landkreisen
verantwortung tragen nutzen die so
nutzen sie die möglichkeiten die wir
noch zur verfügung haben ich biete die
hier ausdrücklich an wir müssen so
schnell wie möglich die hilfe an die an
den menschen bringen und glaube hier
können wir noch so zusagen für die
zukunft einen zahlen zu legen also
bewerben sind noch da danke herr
friedsam dank der wirbel
ich wünsche ihnen noch ein mann
vorstellen der ferdinand a less er ist
bestatter in bonn und
schönen guten abend herr pfeil wir sehen
sie hier bei ihrer sowieso traurigen
arbeit in diesen tagen aber bei einer
arbeit die wohl auch sie fassungslos
macht den guten abend pfahl mittlerweile
haben sie wie viele flutopfer wie viele
leichen bei sich in der leichenhalle die
sie bestatten müssen 26 haben wir zu
zeigen wir sind immer alle bei uns die
sind teilweise gerichtsmedizin gebracht
worden
also sowas habe ich meinem leben noch
nie gesehen
was sind das für menschen die bei ihnen
nun verstorben in der leichenhalle
liegen in den vergangenen tagen als
flutopfer zu ihm gekommen sind sind dass
ältere menschen sind junge menschen weil
du schreck alles also ganz angefangen
von einer mitarbeiterin wurde ich
morgens um 6 uhr geweckt dass ihr mann
ein feuerwehrmann tödlich verunglückt
ist
impfungen ist jetzt die letzte war die
23 jährige die noch gesucht worden ist
das sind alles mögliche an menschen
erhalte junge große kleine das ist
einfach nur schrecklich und schüler
probleme gehabt die abzuholen
duschwasser steine geröll mussten wir
abholen es war wie im krieg und krise
wann war bei ihnen der zeitpunkt dass
sie gespürt haben dass es eine ganz
besondere katastrophe ganz unglaublichen
ausmaßes
wir fahren normalerweise alles im kreis
euskirchen für der polizei da kam uns
ein polizei auto abholen weil wir keine
verbindung mehr hatten
sie haben uns gebeten möglichst viele
teams zusammenzustellen mit den hinter
blauen licht zu fahren weil die straßen
teilweise gesperrt waren also mittwoch
waren wir ungefähr klar dass eine riesen
katastrophe ist aber dass sie so groß
wurde
damit habe ich überhaupt nicht gerechnet
so ist irgendwo auch man kann jetzt
einmal verliert die lust aber es muss
immer irgendwo weiter gehen
wir danken ihnen für ihre so schwierige
arbeit auch in diesen tagen tatsächlich
erschreckende bilder bei ihnen aus ihren
leichenhallen von immer mehr sagen
infolge dieser flugkatastrophe danke für
das gespräch ja das sind die schäden die
in dieser flut katastrophe nie wieder
gutzumachen sind und dann gibt es die
materiellen schäden die auch in die
milliarden höhe gehen werden in die
vielfachen milliarden höhe
und wo es darum geht dass die
finanziellen entschädigungen jetzt
wirklich ganz schnell bei den menschen
ankommen zum beispiel bei den menschen
wie frau weigand dort in rheinland-pfalz
ich habe vorhin mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
gesprochen wann denn wirklich die
fluthilfe nun kommen im übrigen ist mir
als wirtschaftsminister wichtig dass wir
nicht aus dem blick fest dass wir nicht
aus dem blick verlieren dass es viele
viele hundert menschen gibt die doppelt
getroffen sind durch corona und jetzt
durch die flutkatastrophe die bereits
durch corona über viele monate keine
umsätze hatten die ihr letztes geld
investiert haben um ihr hotel oder ihre
gaststätte zu renovieren wieder schick
zu machen für die zukunft wir werden den
materiellen schaden am gebäude und an
den möbeln natürlich ersetzen können
aber ich glaube man muss auch sehen
diese menschen werden erneut einige
monate keinen umsatz haben und deshalb
müssen wir auch da hilfe ins auge fassen
und einer von diesen ist sinan dogan den
ich herzlich begrüße in unserer runde
herr dogan sagen sie uns ganz kurz was
bei ihnen den erheblichen schaden
ausmacht schon guten abend wir hatten
erheblichen schaden muss man sich erst
mal aus zusehen wie die stadt aussieht
das erst mal das was am meisten trifft
es besteht keine infrastruktur es gibt
kein wasser kein strom keine toiletten
das ist das was am meisten liegt überall
nur noch schlamm und geröll zu sehen
das erst mal das was am meisten weh tut
und das nächstes natürlich dass das
geschäft einfach in trümmern liegt die
autos in form von kapital einfach
weggeweht wurden von den wassermassen
und nicht nur das auch die nachbarn
geschäfte ob sie die kios ist die
gebäudereinigung die bäckerei der
friseur alles stimmt wurde nicht
es ist alles zerstört und wenn man
selber nicht vor ort das kann man sich
das vorstellen auch wenn man noch so
viele videos und fotos zugeschickt
bekommt man immer realisiert dass erst
wenn man selber und matt stimmt und und
und selber sieht vor ort was da
eigentlich los ist
sie sind also autoverkäufer sie haben
ein autohaus sie haben alles verloren
komplett alles
jetzt sagt er mir drin stammen bzw 1 um
ein auto stand drin das ist komplett
also das wasser stand bis zur decke
also komplette halle war voller wasser
und die autos die großen stammen die
wurden einfach weggespült
die sind auch nicht mehr aufzufinden und
wenn man sie hoffe sie werden zu müssen
der bundeswirtschaftsminister hat jetzt
einem ersten schwung erst mal gesagt
10.000 euro für unternehmen was würde
ihnen das helfen das rückgrat mehr
reichen um die halle irgendwie auf
eigene art und meistens stand zu setzen
vorschlag
heute würde wahrscheinlich die 10.000
euro kann man wird bei uns am auto haben
wir zum beispiel nicht wie lange ich
aber auch in anderen läden wo waren drin
standen
es sind ja schon heute sogar autos haben
jetzt im hohen wert da war auch andere
geschäfte wo produkte drin gestanden
mit 10.000 euro kommt man dann schweiz
aber es wäre schon als sieger die
buggles mich schnell kommt dieses geld
an und ist auch sagen wieder so wie bei
den chor helfen dass man wochen und
monatelang darauf warten muss oder kommt
das geld dann wirklich schnell und
werden schnell für sie was werden
schnell für sie diese woche also jetzt
die beginnende woche schnell wieder für
mich wenn die politik jetzt wirklich mal
klopft wie sie es immer so schön sagen
und nicht immer behaupten und
vorgeschriebenen text war der andere
lacht sich ja ich weiß nicht was die
politiker sich denken das geld muss
sofort schließen so dass hat man gesehen
darüber wollen wir auch gleich noch kurz
sprechen lassen sie uns einmal kurz bei
den punkt bleiben der wirtschafts hilfen
her anders sie haben genügend erfahrung
wie lange sowas auch dauert in der
bürokratie ich habe mich heute ein
bisschen darüber gewundert dass immer
wieder gesagt wurde na ja wir haben ja
erst am mittwoch unsere kabinettssitzung
und da werden wir das dann beschließen
und gleichzeitig warten im moment
tausende zehntausende menschen darauf
zumindest zu wissen wann kommt das wann
kann ich damit planen dauert das halt
einfach so lange oder könnte man das
nicht doch nur ein bisschen
beschleunigen dass man wirklich sagen
konnte okay wir haben jetzt darüber 45
tage beraten vier tage sind glaube ich
und jetzt ab montag kommen die ersten
hilfe
gibt montag eine sitzung diese wichtig
für die vorbereitung des kabinetts wohl
sowas dann entschieden werden soll das
ist die sitzung der staatssekretäre die
ministerien der minister führen der
drittes comeback vorbereitet matratzen
entscheidungen sind grundsätzlich dazu
morgen treffen und die dann auch
schneller umsetzen es ist verständlich
dass menschen sagen ich will dir
vorhabens montag oder mittwoch das bin
ich jetzt muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
ist natürlich auch sind zwei tage mehr
unsicherheit aber mittwoch wäre da habe
ich auch noch angebracht wichtig und da
habe ich ein bisschen gezockt in ihrem
und interview gerade eben die partei als
peter altmaier die krone hilfen erwähnt
hat denn jeder weiß was das für chaos
war in seinem ministerium und wie lange
die menschen gewartet haben da drauf
bist der erste gelder geflossen sind
also dem vergleich den er selber
angestrengt hat das stimmt mich nicht
sehr fröhlich und nicht sehr
zuversichtlich aber ich hoffe dass man
daraus gelernt hat und jetzt hat sich
auch ganz schnell frei zugänglich macht
ich habe mit ihm tatsächlich darüber
gesprochen wir haben das gespräch ein
bisschen geschnitten wir können das
gerne in ganzer länge später noch
veröffentlichten ich habe ihn genau
darauf angesprochen auf die november
hilfen und der rat tatsächlich
versprochen dass genau das nicht
passieren wird dass menschen so lange
auf ihr geld warten werden hier tritt
ihn
genau weil wir dieses misstrauen bei
herrn dogan ja auch hören weil vieles
eben in der korona krise so lange
gedauert hat
haben sie verständnis dafür dass jetzt
eben viele leute sagen mensch der start
der ist meistens da kommt dann schon
irgendwie was ja aber es dauert halt
alles so lange ich glaube das nicht dass
das schnell und unbürokratisch gerade
läuft ja ich fand das ein bisschen ich
habe auch gezuckt als bezahlt mal das
wort novemberhälfte in den mund nahmen
ich kenne mehrere unternehmen und
menschen in meinem wahlkreis die haben
die november hilfe ende februar bekommen
das ist etwas was die flutopfern
überhaupt nicht durchhalten werden
ich kann mir also nur wünschen das ist
dieses mal anders läuft und dass es
vielleicht so läuft wie in der ersten
hälfte die in der ersten ko-runde
ausgezahlt worden sind da ist er
teilweise innerhalb von wochen frist
gezahlt worden und deswegen finde ich
auch obmann man hätte auch montag eine
sondersitzung des kabinetts machen
können macht man aus anderen anlässen ja
auch aber auch die zwei tage kommt es
nicht an es kommt darauf an dass das
geld jetzt fließt nach dem ist
freigegeben worden des wieder
bundesfinanzministers angekündigt das
wünschen
und noch im juli bei den menschen an das
wünsche ihnen noch im juli sagte trittin
das wünsche ihnen herr erdogan danke für
das gespräch mit ihnen ich würde gerne
her anders und herr trittin noch eine
frage diskutieren die natürlich wichtig
ist die in den letzten tagen vor allen
dingen von der grünen seite immer wieder
auch natürlich diskutiert wurde
sehen sie herr trittin im moment einen
klaren zusammenhang zwischen dieser
flutkatastrophe und dem klimawandel in
deutschland in europa ich weiß gar nicht
wer das anders sieht wenn ich herrn
seehofer ein laschet und andere gehört
habe das hat was mit der physik zu tun
es ist unbestreitbar dass das klima in
den letzten jahren immer wärmer geworden
dass die rekordjahre folgen sich immer
kürzer heißere luft kann mehr
feuchtigkeit speichern und dies erhöht
die wahrscheinlichkeit mit starkregen
ereignissen trotzdem ist es falsch zu
behaupten
diese starkregen ereignis als solches
hat es sozusagen nur wegen des
klimawandels geht ihm aber es ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit für solche ereignisse
durch die globale erwärmung größer
geworden es ist im übrigen noch ein
zweites hinzu gekommen
die folgen werden größer wenn sie sich
die mittelgebirge anschauen in denen der
borkenkäfer wütet und die gesamten
fichtenmonokulturen flach gelegt hat
diese wälder fallen zurzeit als zurück
die becken für massive regenfälle
einfach aus die haben früher regen
gesammelt heute aus das wasser
ungebremst zu tal
das heißt wir haben ist nicht nur damit
zu tun dass wir eine weitere globale
erwärmung verhindern müssen dass sie auf
den 1,5 grad frage kommen müssen sondern
wir müssen auch viel mehr tun was die
anpassung an geht das hat was mit
hochwasservorsorge zu tun das hat aber
auch etwas damit zu tun wie wir unsere
wälder nach dem borkenkäfer wieder so
aufforsten dass sie künftig wieder als
wasserreservoir etwas taugen damit es
eben nicht in den engen ort drang fließt
veranda gehen sie davon aus dass diese
flutkatastrophe die natürlich jetzt
völlig zu recht über innerhalb von
wenigen tagen die korea krise völlig hat
verschwinden lassen im grunde aus der
öffentlichen diskussion dass diese
flugkatastrophe die bundestagswahl
zumindest mit entscheiden wird dafür ist
es noch zu früh aber die bundestagswahl
ags ist oder der wahlkampf aktion jetzt
des großes thema in auseinandersetzungen
annalena baerbock uns das wirklich viel
viel größer nun was wir sehen wenn sie
fragen was sind wichtige themen im
bundestagswahlkampf dann wird man immer
wieder klimawandel gesundheit rente
arbeit ist auch so ein thema aber das
ist immer sehr theoretisch jetzt mit
dieser katastrophe mit diesem
katastrophalen ausmaßen und den
nachvollziehbaren gründen jürgen trittin
hier gerade erwähnt hat er ist das erste
große thema wirklich da und hier geht es
dann um die nicht nur nicht nur die
frage woher kommt das alles und mehr und
was ist dafür zuständig sondern auch den
blick in die zukunft was kann man tun um
das zu verhindern
es geht aber auch darum wie geht man mit
dieser krise oben schaffe ich dass wir
ihr vertrauen und zuversicht zu erwecken
empathie zu zeigen und auch das ganze
dann tatsächlich durch tatkraft
umzusetzen denn soviel nur dazu es wird
ja immer gesagt jetzt schröder als ich
damals 2002 die gummistiefel angezogen
ist dann einfach ins hochwassergebiet
gefahren es war ja viel mehr
es war das hofer
das gesetz das ihr in trittin erwähnt
hat es war eine steuersenkung nicht
umgesetzt wurde und es waren maßnahmen
neben dieser empathie und das auch es
jetzt auch und da wird es spannend sein
zu sehen wer das wie schafft empathie
sprechen sie an heran da da muss ich
natürlich noch mal auf die szene zu
sprechen kommen die erdogan gerade schon
angesprochen hat die er vermutlich auch
in den sozialen netzwerken gestern
gesehen hat rauf und runter also frank
walter steinmeier der bundespräsident
richtet sich gerade mit mitgefühl mit
empathie an die angehörigen der
flutopfern aldi die betroffen sind und
hinten scherz und feixt und lacht der
unions kanzlerkandidat und
nrw-ministerpräsident armin laschet herr
trittin als sie das gesehen haben muss
man sagen das kann passieren man denkt
sich über jeden moment nach und
natürlich darf man auch mal lachen in
der politik oder ist das was
unverzeihlich ist aus ihrer sicht was
völlig ungeschicktes was völlig
unpassendes armin laschet hat das selber
als unpassend bezeichnet und hat sich
dafür entschuldigt und ich finde stimmig
béla anda zu wir sollten uns jetzt sehr
ernsthaft nicht polemisch
ich glaube auch nicht dass die grünen
alles richtig machen aber im sinne eines
wettstreits von konzepten wie wir eine
weitere globale erwärmung tatsächlich
begrenzen und wie wir uns gemeinsam
diese gesellschaft auf die folgen des
klimawandels auf die folgen der
klimakrise besser einstellen damit ist
nicht solche katastrophalen ereignisse
gibt das sollte den streit den streit
und konzepte im wahlkampf wert sein
und ich finde das ist wichtiger als das
was herr laschet gemacht hat wie gesagt
ich nehme seine entschuldigung erst mal
ernst wobei ja andere ja auch gesagt hat
dass er im partie ebenso wichtig ist und
das haben eben viele gestern so bedeutet
das dass nägel besonders große ausdruck
von der partie war
béla anda kriegt man so war es nochmal
aus den köpfen weil diese szene bilder
haben eine ganz starke wirkung dieses
bild gestern hatte eine starke wirkung
geht das noch mal raus aus denen
köpfen der wähler also bei mir geht es
nicht raus und ich muss sagen gerade
wenn ich noch mal sehe dann kriege ich
schon zu viel
ich finde es gut dass er sich
entschuldigt hat und wird ganz sagen
damit ist es auch gut haben hier
irgendwie mal getwittert aber eher nicht
gesagt das darf einen nicht passieren
und es ist ja nicht nur durch die
sozialen netzwerke gegangen ist um die
welt gegangen
der guardian hat damit aufgemacht werden
immer online über 35 millionen
leserinnen und leser also und nicht nur
die rams gemacht das ist ein
es darf ein eigentlich nicht als
spitzenpolitiker passieren so etwas und
es ist ähnlich verrückt mehr kann nicht
anders wenn ich das nicht sie tun ihren
die peer steinbrück stinkefinger im
wahlkampf 2013 das sind dinge die muss
man wissen und ja nur gut dass er sich
entschuldigt hat aber ausland geht das
nicht béla anda vergleicht das lasche
lachen gestern mit peer steinbrück
stinkefinger
auch das nehmen wir mit aus dieser
allerdings sehr ernsthaften sendung sehr
wichtigen sendung der wer über grosse
lehren aus dieser flugkatastrophe
diskutiert haben wenn es auch gleich
noch so früh so wenige tage nach dieser
unbeschreiblichen katastrophe wo wir
über den katastrophenschutz gesprochen
haben ich danke ihnen beiden jürgen
trittin béla anda und möchte ihnen aber
auch zeigen was ich male peter altmaier
noch besprochen habe über genau diesen
armin laschet lacher ja ich habe diese
szene auch nachträglich im internet
gesehen und ich finde es gut und richtig
dass armin laschet sich dafür
entschuldigt hat dass er selbst gesagt
hat das war nicht angemessen
und ich glaube das ist der richtige
umgang mit dieser wirklich nicht ganz
nicht ganz einfach nachzuvollziehen und
sie tut aber fanden sie das ungerecht
dass man das danach thematisiert oder
fanden sie es von ihm ungeschickt sich
in dem moment so zu verhalten als als
politiker müssen wir damit leben dass
unser verhalten beobachtet wird das ist
kommentiert wird die das ist übrigens
parteiübergreifend der fall
auch frau berbalk
musste und muss sich gefallen lassen
dass ihr verhalten beobachtet und
kommentiert wird
und in diesem fall war es so dass
offenbar doch ganz viele pickel
bürgerinnen und bürger sich sehr
irritiert füllten die das mitbekommen
haben das hat man in den sozialen medien
gesehen und deshalb war es gut dass
armin laschet dann richtig anschließend
gehandelt sie kennen wie kaum jemand
anders im politischen leben die
kanzlerin aus nächster nähe
ich fand die frage stellte sich danach
so ein bisschen wäre ihr so etwas
passiert und die antwort wäre
wahrscheinlich gewesen
ja aber ich finde das ist jetzt genau
der punkt wo wir sehr genau aufpassen
müssen dass wir nicht von der bewertung
von realen vorgängen hin zu
spekulationen und annahmen kommen
es gab eine konkrete situation das war
nicht glücklich das hat armin laschet
selbst korrigiert und jetzt glaube ich
wäre es auch gut wenn wir uns wieder den
wirklich in großen problemen zuwenden
nämlich der hilfe für die menschen vor
ort
und das tun wir am ende der sendung
wieder genauso wie wir diese sendung
auch eröffnet haben nämlich mit einem
blick in die aktuellen flut
krisengebiete wir waren heute in
rheinland-pfalz wir waren nordrhein
westfalen haben ohnehin den ganzen tag
über hierbei bild live berichtet aus den
gebieten der flugkatastrophe und wir
haben heute auch gesehen dass eben auch
in bayern es jetzt diese
katastrophengebiete gibt unter anderem
in berchtesgaden von wo heute diese
bilder kamen nämlich ebenfalls von
schwersten überschwemmungen und von
einer völlig zerstörten rodelbahn auch
dort in berchtesgaden die wir unter
anderem alle kennen von ja auch großen
erfolgen von deutschen roth land
insbesondere von georg hackl dem hackl
schorsch in berchtesgaden und mit dem
bin ich vor zu später stunde jetzt noch
verbunden eine stunde vor mitternacht
danke dass sie noch zur verfügung stehen
herr hackl
ich musste heute bei diesen bildern
sofort an sie denken deswegen wäre es
mir so wichtig mit ihnen noch kurz
sprechen zu können an diesem tag die
rodelbahn von berchtesgaden völlig ja zu
geschlampt muss man sagen eigentlich
auch ein trümmerfeld was ist ihnen da
heute durch den kopf gegangen als sie
wussten wie sie eben bei ihnen auf der
rodelbahn bei ihnen vor der haustür
aussieht ja so guten namen das
berchtesgaden ich muss server zuerst
einmal song wir sind im herzen alle bei
denen menschen die am schwersten
betroffen sind im hort hall vor allen
dingen auch bei uns gibt es menschen die
viel viel verloren haben und da ist
natürlich da der schaden an der
rennrodelbahn es ist ein materieller
schaden er ist apokalyptisch er ist
irrsinnig groß aber gott sei dank sind
hier keine menschenopfer zu beklagen das
ist einmal die gute nachricht aber diese
bauen die ist nachhaltig zerstört und es
werden ja im kommenden winter sowieso
nicht aber wir sind gespannt
so etwas jemals wieder repariert werden
kann wir hoffen das beste wir drücken
die daumen aber es ist schon es ist
schon heftig was hier passiert ist
also sie zweifeln daran dass das jemals
wieder aufgebaut werden könnte ihr baby
sozusagen ihre rodelbahn
naja die schäden direkt an der bahn sind
sind reparierbar zweifellos mit einem
sehr massiven großen aufwand aber oben
natürlich dass das gebirge oberhalb so
abgesichert werden kann dass hier wieder
unter sicheren bedingungen der betrieb
stattfinden kann das muss man üben
was erwarten sie denn jetzt aus
berchtesgadener sich zusammen schon
gesagt die allerschwersten und
allerschlimmsten bilder die kommen noch
aus anderen regionen aber eben auch bei
ihnen gibt es ganz schwere schäden heute
was erwarten sie konkret und was
brauchen sie an hilfen
ja ich konnte ich kann selber weniger zu
sorgen weil ich war eigentlich die
letzte nacht durchgehend beschäftigt und
unten heute mit erst mit wasser aus dem
eigenen keller zu schöpfen und den
keller auszuräumen
ich habe also wenige nachrichten gesehen
ich habe mir und am tag ein bild
verschafft von den zuständen an der
rodelbahn und auf dem weg dorthin und
zurück habe einiges wahrnehmen können
dass häuser bis zum zum dach in einer
mure gesteckt haben und ja also es ist
viel passiert aber ich kenne die genauen
ausmaße und die die zahl der einzelnen
opfer bis dato nicht was es denn bei
ihnen zu hause los gewesen also ihnen es
selber das haus voll gelaufen sie waren
die ganze nacht beschäftigt das wasser
herauszupumpen
ja okay hier hatte ein vergleichsweise
geringen schaden da etwas wasser im
keller musste kurz bangen dass mir die
hause liegt richtig topsoft aber wir
haben das abwenden können und dann was
gut das ist kein problem hin zu werden
ein wort bitte von ihnen weil sie
national einfach so bekannt sind und
immer jemand war mit dem sich ganz ganz
viele in deutschland wirklich
identifizieren konnten
auch weil sie einfach immer so
bodenständig fahren deswegen ein wort
vielleicht von ihnen auch nach zb altena
wo wir in dieser sendung die
bürgermeistern gehört haben frau weigand
aus diesen schwer betroffenen gebieten
ahrweiler rheinland pfalz oder ganz
genauso nach zu den menschen in diesen
so betroffenen gebieten in nordrhein
westfalen
ja okay also solche ereignisse habe
vorhin mitbekommen dass irgendwie
versucht wurde hier irgendwelche
schuldzuweisungen zu geben da muss ich
wirklich sagen da muss man in der
situation abstand davon nehmen weil man
kann sehr wohl die warnungen des
deutschen wetterdienstes wahrnehmen
ernst nehmen so ernst nehmen wie es nur
eben geht und es war klar dass viel viel
regen kommt und es war bei uns auch klar
was wussten wir alle aber was diese
regen im einzelnen an den einzelnen
stellen macht das konnte keiner
voraussehen das konnte keiner wissen
davon wurden wir alle überrascht und für
mich kein wunder dass auch das
technische hilfswerk völlig überfahren
war von der situation und aber wir
müssen eines daraus lernen
diese ereignisse werden wir in zukunft
öfter erleben und das hat
unterschiedliche gründe wie wir menschen
unsere landschaft verändern wo wir jetzt
da wälder absterben und die nicht mehr
unserer karte becken denen ob wir mehr
immer mehr flächen auch versiegeln in
den oberläufen von bächen und flüssen
oder insgesamt wie ob sich das klima
einfach verändert das sind alles
allesamt gründe die in der summe zu
solchen ereignissen führen
dass wir in der zukunft nicht weniger
werden wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
sagt georg hackl der so erfolgreiche
rennrodler dem im moment vor der haustür
seine rodelbahn heute verloren gegangen
ist ich glaube das muss man sagen auch
das gehört zu dieser flugkatastrophe 20
21 die so viele schockierende
schreckliche bilder geliefert hat und
die jetzt 1 glaube ich brauche wirklich
zusammenstehen in deutschland und alle
miteinander anpacken dort helfen wo wir
alle denjenigen die so schwer getroffen
wurden helfen können danke georg tacke
für das gespräch hier zu später stunde
bei bild live und wir sind zurück mit
den richtigen fragen am nächsten sonntag
um 21 45
[Musik]